[Music]
here's your money briefing for Friday
June 23rd I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
for teens it's easier than ever to sign
up for payment apps to gain Financial
Freedom and even though many apps have
launched versions geared toward teens
that freedom comes with some risks and
often requires parental oversight we'll
hear from a parent of twin 15 year olds
in a moment but first wsj personal
finance reporter Oyen adodoyan joins us
so oyan what are some examples of apps
that have launched special accounts for
teens Amazon Uber cash app venmo even
Fidelity Investments have launched
specialized teen accounts in recent
years for teenagers between the ages of
13 and 17. and what does it allow them
to do it basically allows them to create
their own identities on these accounts
that are usually attached to a parent's
account and it gives them their own
spending power they can maybe even trade
stocks they can create savings accounts
and many of these accounts are also
linked to a debit card why are they
marketing themselves to teens and what
rewards do these tech companies reap
from targeting younger customers I spoke
with someone who has experience working
with fintech companies and he was
telling me that Banks and companies like
uber venmo cash app like to create a
certain stickiness with their customers
so when someone is involved with a bank
when they're young maybe as a teenager
they're less likely to leave that bank
when they grow older and progress into
adulthood so for these apps it can be a
benefit to them to attract a younger
audience at an earlier time and keep
them for longer you mentioned stock
trading and saving and purchasing they
require some sort of Parental
involvement before a team can sign up
yes so for many of these apps people
under the age of 18 could not have their
own accounts so in the cases of a venmo
or cash app or even a Fidelity
Investment account they have to have a
link from a parent who already has an
account in that system so that the team
can then create their own account with
that parental oversight Arizona resident
Layla Haisha the mother of 15 year old
twins has been providing some of that
oversight so Leila your son and daughter
have downloaded an assortment of apps
but you actually got your daughter
started with a payment app when she was
seven tell us about that and what you
were hoping she would learn about
Banking and spending well yes I have
three kids and at the time she was
really wanting to have her own money so
it worked for everyone to get on the
same page as far as how they're going to
be paid for their chores so when I
select a green light that would
attracted me to it was that I could
track their chores they could check it
off and then they would be paid for that
and then they could manage their money
how do you keep an eye on their
transactions with green light app there
is a parent approval so anything that
they want to exchange shares on their
stock market I have to approve it for
other things such as expenses I can just
see what's happening instead parameters
on how much they can spin and discuss
budgeting with them on what they're
going to spend on food or shopping and I
can see everything in real time and some
of these apps allow teens to do stock
trading how do you feel about that yes I
didn't realize that until my son is the
one who's very interested in the stock
market and he said hey Mom on Greenlight
we are able to do some purchase of
stocks in exchange and I am really
learning a lot from him and it does
require my husband or I to approve any
of the changes that he wants to make
with his portfolio that he's developing
what sorts of lessons have your children
learned along the way in terms of
finances and using these apps I feel
they have very much learned more about
financial literacy and how they are in
control of their accounts their funds
and the importance of not not only
saving but also in investing have you
had to raise any red flags or input some
rules about not doing something or not
downloading certain apps when they were
younger there were a lot of the fun apps
with games and a lot of those games
would have these add-ons that they
weren't quite aware of that you know
you're buying extra stars but they
didn't realize the currency of it and I
think having this knowledge and being in
control at their funds now they can see
like oh that actually took money away so
it does help in that manner as far as
spending we really do have to have a
conversation sometimes I'm realizing
like Amazon boxes have been showing up
quite a bit at the front door and you
know when my son wanted to make a larger
investment in his stock and make an
exchange my husband and I we talked like
well it's either you know he wants to do
this and understand the risk and this is
a good lesson for him to learn of course
nothing that we wouldn't feel would be
too too absorbitant but definitely
something that if he was going to spend
it on a pair of tennis shoes would
probably be the same amount so this is
something that he has to do research so
they are learning a lot what sort of an
experience is this for you and your
husband and working with your kids and
with these apps because this is probably
not how you and your husband learned
financial literacy when you were growing
up it absolutely is and is completely
different I remember sitting with my mom
and learning how to balance a checkbook
and that is so old school now and it's
especially you know my oldest daughter
just graduated from high school and got
a lot of checks for her graduation gifts
but she's like can they just send me a
vimo but we've had to learn how to adapt
and I think that's with anything with
parenting and learning to see really we
need to meet our kids where they are and
of course know what the safety
parameters are around that but we are
now living in this age that is digital
and they are able to get money for
babysitting digitally through venmo
through green light through cash app
they're not using checks and going to
the bank so we're learning around it
just like any other aspect of parenting
that's Arizona resident Layla High Shaw
Layla thank you for being with us thank
you
reporter Oyen adidoyan is back with us
with these apps Oyen the kids are
learning about money and digital
transactions well what about good
old-fashioned cash well teens these days
don't really have experience with cash
funny enough when I was interviewing the
teenagers and their parents something
that came up often was this idea that
they tend to spend more money when it
comes to cash because they're not seeing
that digital number decline on an app or
in a bank account so for them the idea
of paper money almost feels like fake
money oh well that cash is very real no
there's there's nothing fake about it
and one of the teens that I talked with
actually went to an amusement park
recently and all the vendors were cash
only and she was saying that she was
thankful that her mom had reminded her
to at least bring a couple bucks with
her otherwise she wouldn't have been
able to pay for anything is there a
concern that with all the activity going
on in the apps and a lot of this is new
to the teens especially stock trading
and and just making purchases on their
own is there a fear they could fall into
trap and commit some sort of misstep
along the way parent are definitely
concerned about that when it comes to
these apps and Layla actually mentioned
that for her she had to have a
conversation with her husband about
whether or not they should allow their
son to have money to put into
Investments because that's something
that they didn't have experience with
when they were his age and so he is
involving himself with a certain level
of risk that they had to weigh if it was
something that they wanted to allow him
to do and ultimately they decided to let
him have that money and invest it into
the stock market but they were
definitely nervous doing so that's Wall
Street Journal personal finance reporter
Oyen adedoyan and that's it for your
money briefing this week our supervising
producer is Melanie Roy and our
executive producer is Chris zinsley I'm
your host J.R Whalen thanks for
listening and have a great weekend
[Music]
thank you